welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm grace Helbig your host this
episode as always is very exciting we
have Remi Cruz you know her as a what we
call influencers in the biz she is a
lifestyle guru on YouTube she's also got
a hilariously adorable podcast pretty
basic with her friend Alicia she's just
like a genuinely hilarious fun like
beauty guru in flicks she's a girl
that's got it together then also doesn't
like what I relate to very much so enjoy
this episode with Remi Cruz I bet you
have great ideas that you are itching to
turn into a reality well guess what
Squarespace is here for you they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're showcasing your
work or selling products of any kind
they've beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
you can easily make a beautiful website
all on your own but if you get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain Remi cruise hello hello
previously Remy ashton rebranding thank
you no one ever calls it out thank you
so much I like it I think it's great I
was well I asked cuz I was like it's
wait am I tweeting to the wrong person
I don't want this to be a fake account
and I don't want to also offend her if
she's like that's my like I didn't know
if you've got a secret divorce or
something and that was your last name
and you changed it back and I was like I
don't know all the details of this
that's way more exciting than I just
when I was like 18 decided to use my
middle name because I wasn't supposed to
use my last name on YouTube at the time
oh really my parents were like
absolutely not and then once it came out
I was like well I hate my middle name
what did I do this to myself and then
I've been trying to subtly do it and
then I get offended now when I got him
people are like Remi ash and I'm like no
one's paying attention I saw it I saw it
and yeah so you signed up for YouTube
when you're 18 um well this channel I
started when I was in my main channel
now
I was like 18 and then I've been
watching YouTube forever
yeah and then before this I had like
other channels and then I was deleted
them so this one 18 I really started
probably like 15 16 okay but your
parents knew yes well it is she knew
what was happening they didn't
understand they just thought I was
making videos in my bedroom and which is
an yeah for parents you're like what the
[ __ ] is that exactly
Asian parent they weren't too happy
about it
so they told you couldn't use your last
name for safety reason well also it's
just like a I started as a beauty guru
sure all in all the girls were always it
was like Miss blank your middle name or
like right Blair Fowler was it's like
all those like little user names like
that so it like wasn't a jersey start
yes just our seven I loved all of those
names I like oh I grew up as such a
fangirl
of em yeah of everyone oh I remember
watching my first makeup tutorial online
and being obsessed I was in New York and
this like producer guy was like you and
your friend should make parodies of
these beauty gurus and I was like what
does that mean and then I went and I was
like I love this I feel like genuinely
loved this and went down a wormhole of
being like yeah show me all your hauls
show me everything you bought from
forever21 Michelle Phan did a video like
how to stretch your shoes with ice or
something like how to get your makeup
compact back in when you dropped it I
was like yes all of my makeup looks like
that hey can you throw it on the ground
I loved it okay so tell me tell me what
went through your brain when you made
your first video on that channel yeah
the one now I had just gotten my
driver's license uh-huh and I was really
stoked so I drove I didn't have much
money okay I drove myself to Walmart
I was going to student council camp
summer camp wait you're gone okay it
wasn't the student council at camp yes
so it's like a leadership camp okay
hello
the University of California Santa
Barbara okay um I would I was going for
my first year I know no second year I
was a real veteran at this time and I
drove myself to Walmart and they had it
was like a leadership thing where they
taught you how to be like a good student
council member but then also these are
like the crazy party kids of house I
don't know what I was doing there trust
me wait
crazy party kids in the school counselor
camp I feel like everybody in a speeds
like at schools and high schools either
like the cool kids or like the really
like lame ones who just like wanted to
like part a store
my school was like the coolest kid I
don't know how I got on well I thought
it was an interview process that's how I
got voted in and so they would throw
these like dances at night and that were
like these like honest like ragers cool
they were like themes and it was like
but it was student council camp so like
within reason yeah girl look I went to
Latin club camp like four times
all different colleges but when you're
in high school and you get to spend a
week on the college campus out your
parents without your parents and you
turn your sheet into a toga and you're
like I'm the coolest [ __ ] person
that's ever lived
yeah but I had to prep myself for this
ASB camp obvious yeah Walmart in a
famous like Disney and like under the
sea so I bought myself like a sequined
top yes and a Disney fan pack and that
is no it's private enough amazing so
that was what five six years ago that
was I think coming up on seven wow
that's so nuts I can't believe it I mean
I was listening to you and Alicia's
podcast this morning no no I I say that
too and attend people I look at anything
I'm like I apologize I think it's really
really cool what you guys are doing
right now because I was like whoa
they're so candid on this and the
episode that you guys are talking about
the stress of having to like grow up
with your audience and not be afraid
change and not be afraid to be like I'm
like you're 23 for 24 24 like I'm 24 now
I'm not 18 anymore so I'm gonna be
talking about drinking and dating and
things like that and because that's what
my life is right now and if you're gonna
want to watch me for authenticity this
is authentically what I'm going through
right now I thought that was really cool
and it was really fun to listen to to
friends talk about the pressure and
stress of it all how my bigger which is
like how did this podcast come about
like did you guys feel like boxed in by
videos and want to be able to talk more
like openly about everything well first
of all thank you yeah
basically I honestly don't listen to
podcasts I forget everything I will
forget everything we talked about
immediately when I leave this or so but
we've already talked about I think for
me it was never really an idea and I
remember basically one day it was like
September of last year I must I've
always really loved doing YouTube I feel
like with my channel being a lifestyle
channel I'm able to really kind of
change the content so I don't really get
too bored but I do a lot of people get
get boxed in with that kind of stuff so
I understand that but I was just happy
with YouTube doing that and then I got a
call actually know my manager sat me
down one day in September last year
they're like hey a company came towards
you they want to know if you wanna do a
podcast so I was like hmm yeah I don't
listen I don't know and then the next
day I got a call from my agent and
Alicia and I both share an agent yeah
and he was like hey idea podcast the you
and Alicia yeah not even think house
yeah totally I just said no yesterday I
knew she was like what exactly so I had
to like make this whole call I like I
felt very official I like texted Emma
was like we need to take it call it 3:30
please everybody put in your calendar
they call me like what do you want I was
like so remember yesterday I said no
podcast I've decided I'm going to do one
now with Alicia it's gonna be great but
it was kind of just like because Alicia
and I would go out to join our manager
with our agent sometimes just like hang
out and mmm specifically one story I was
telling was about this guy who I like to
refer to as stellar
he was actually from a YouTube video my
friend set me up with him because I
wanted to do this video where I took a
guy on a date
okay I'm one of the followers control it
I was like this is a great nothing can
go wrong
that gives me anxiety just hearing about
this don't think I thought I know I
didn't so I brought him in and obviously
from the name we know how that played
out and so I was just telling him
everything telling our agent like oh my
god this is this and then she ran you
the story so she was just kind of like
jumping in and then you
next couple days he was like you guys
need a podcast like the people that hear
this because I never talked about dating
really ever on my channel right or and
it felt very obviously like it's not
scripted but it's like when you're
talking by yourself in a video you can
only say so much it's not a conversation
so he was just like this is a whole
other side that people need to see mhm
so then I talked to my manager I was
like podcast like okay sounds good so
that's kind of how it came to be and
then also just us being best friends at
that time we were just trying to get
close yeah and I feel like there's not
really like a lifestyle or and nobody in
that genre of YouTube is doing it so
yeah let's try it that's awesome and you
guys seem to spend so much time together
too much time but I'm like how do you
podcast with each other without feeling
like you've already said everything that
you have to say to each other that's a
good question mamrie and I podcast
together and we literally when we come
to see each other are not allowed to
talk to each other until we turn
microphones on because we know that will
spill the beans yeah like stories we
want to tell and then we don't have to
go on and like act like it's the first
time we've heard a story but you guys
seem to constantly have stuff to say to
each other that hasn't already been said
that of like what's going on I've
actually never thought about it that way
I feel like now that you said it the
podcast is yeah I have no idea do you
have a like code of conduct between the
two of you of how much you like how
personally you get on the podcast or how
much you say about each other or
yourselves here's my problem I am an
open book
yeah she's got boundaries I know when to
stop and if we say too much you know I
get it
talking to after I always say a little
too much yeah yeah yeah but yeah we've
got boundaries with her for sure that's
good it's good to understand and respect
the other person I'm gonna be like yeah
I'm just gonna vomit until you clean it
up exactly editor will take care of it
yeah it'll only be between us have you
ever had someone that you've talked
about in the podcast contact you because
they've heard it yes specifically the
one where I talked about losing my
virginity uh-huh um a few days later I
got a very condescending text message
about home if I wanted to talk about my
feelings and what had happened
Wow that person Wow I thought I had
block so that was you know I didn't even
care that he cared I just like I'm bad
at myself for now blocking separately I
need to take a problem up with that boy
but that's so I mean it's really fun I
think to hear about the dating life
scenario of you now do you feel pressure
to that like I have to have dating
stories or or if I go out on a date
maybe they'll have listened to the fact
that I talk about dates candidly well
huh Alicia I was totally sure that she
needs to int when we wrote up the
summary Oh like what the podcast is
gonna be we mentioned boys drama right
so now I feel the need to like bring it
yeah but Alicia doesn't want a date
right now which is totally fine so now I
feel exactly the other stuff I've
learned you know we've done this for
like I think it's coming up on 7 months
now cool and you know I've learned a lot
yeah about what to share and what not to
the day before it came out I went on a
date uh-huh and I was like oh like
telling the guy about it was really cool
and then you know the weeks after it was
still new I didn't really know what to
say I fully went into every detail of
our dates but yeah yeah so I learned
that one the hard way um we'll talk to
him anymore no I've learned really cute
things to myself and you know talk about
it once it's done right right right but
that took about six months to learn Wow
I mean and it's but that's part of the
charm you know it's part of the brand
okay so you you went to college for a
little bit you studied psychology yes
whoa I did a little bit of a we we do
have the most minimal amount of research
possible and basically this whole
podcast is me just fact-checking gonna
be like is this true your brother you
got in a fight over a washing machine oh
my god where did you learn that we have
a researcher
but wait okay that what we'll get to the
punching him in the face over a washing
machine but you went to college for how
long a year and three weeks okay I say
three weeks because after two weeks you
don't get your tuition back yes the hard
way Wow like hard life lessons wow I
didn't know that
yeah that's helpful for people that you
know might be wrong about two weeks at
14 day grace period exactly what was the
because I I went to college but and I
know a lot of people that have gone and
dropped out and that to me is super
scary like what was that decision like
for you um for me I went into school
fully expecting to go into the medical
field yeah and so I was fully prepared
for that and then once I got to college
I was like oh not for me college it went
very horribly wrong for me uh-huh and
then once I started my second year at
the end of the first year I asked my
parents like can YouTube started kind of
picking up for me and I talked was on my
parents down and I was like can I just
try this just like full force I want to
see if I can do it my dad he was paying
for college was like please take as much
time off as my mother she was like no
you're going to school you're gonna be a
doctor you're gonna do this I was like
okay and so I went into my second year
like god ah how it's like fully like
prepared to go yeah three weeks and I
two weeks that I called my parents I
could check the car I was like I can't
juggle both and I really really really
want to just try this YouTube thing like
please let me figure it out like let me
just try hmm week passes three week
three eat that I got for later and my
mom is finally okay like try it for a
year give your all if it works out cool
yeah you're going back to school so I
have a sniffle you're fine and so did
that but then says I had the least I
gotta say out there
best year of my life got to like hang
out my college friend Thank You Bo there
at class it was so great and I just like
worked my ass off for that year and then
I think from then I dropped or I jumped
from like 200 K to like 708 or K so I
got pretty exponentially during that
year yeah
and then luckily was able to make it a
career got out and they moved straight
to LA Wow and how long ago did you move
to LA for four and a half years
something like that yeah
that's nuts and you were also in a
sorority and yeah yeah do you still get
to be in the sorority if you've left um
you know I don't think so I get the
emails asking for my money yeah I
remember somehow while dropping out I
still wanted to be a part of the
sorority live the college life which I
shouldn't have but I still got to like I
somehow finesse my way into picking up
like a little sis mm-hmm but I didn't go
to any meetings I don't think I was
paying for dues anymore I remember being
in like the weird cult like yes it was
like dark people rang like sheets I was
at the meetings I didn't know summer
feeling when everyone was like sitting
these songs and like chants and things I
just stand there like a wedding crasher
but paid for exactly a cold cold
experience what was the the is rushing
is that what's called yes what was that
Lisa um well my school was pretty lame
we didn't have like sorority houses
mm-hmm there was no hazing which is
great it was like a week-long actually
fun fact I did a video about like my
whole process after oh yeah and there
was a girl who's on YouTube who I like
worshipped who went to my school before
me and was in like one of the really
pretty girls sororities I did not make
the cut
so I'm leaving this video after like
basically talking about how I got cut
from all the pretty girls sororities but
I was like really sad like oh like what
are those like a stereotypical saying is
whatever like I don't know I found my
homeboy hole long maybe my family my
sisters for life
like it's not for years it's for life I
mean it's like video Mike in my dorm
room I'm like crying and then that like
picked up a lot of like traffic from
other sorority girls so now people come
to me like I went through recruitment
because of you and I'm like oh no it's
really miss and I'm sure that girl that
I like went off about in the video about
how much I loved her like watched it I
scare sometimes at the gym and I'm like
don't worry I'm so sorry I've never said
a word to her ever be like
no she knows he's like the fangirls oh
that's grimy those are the cringes but
your intentions were good that's the
silver lining and all those cringe
videos and we wish we never made but at
the time we were so confident I was like
this important okay we're gonna take a
quick break and then speaking of the gym
I want to talk to you about fitness
journey and all that fun stuff which I'm
sure you're [ __ ] sick of talking
about so let's dive into it with more
not Judy hey guess what
you got dreams that you want to turn
into a reality I a company for you
they're called Squarespace they're back
supporting us get ready here we go
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project I'm talking
you want to start a new business
showcase your work publish content sell
products or more Squarespace is the tool
for you
guess what they got beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with just a few clicks so you can easily
build a beautiful website all by
yourself
plus they have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there is nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real head to
squarespace.com slash grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain again at squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace guess what this
episode nitro deep is brought to you by
skin there are those among us with an
insatiable thirst for adventure the ones
who embrace the unknown with wide-eyed
wonder although your dreams might take
you worlds away you shouldn't neglect
what's right in front of you
skins new line of intimate devices is
designed to take your pleasure to new
undiscovered places like the skin vibes
a quiet yet pow
full massager made to meet your unique
needs and body skin vibes has a curved
sensual shape it can take you from zero
to Oh with twenty different speeds and
pulsations because when it comes to
pleasure there's no one-size-fits-all
don't settle for monotony explore
intimacy with skin vibes available for
purchase at Rite Aid skin feel
everything you've had like a major
fitness journey which has become part of
this thing which I know probably in in
theory was like a really fun and like
cool thing to document and like held you
accountable and all that but it must be
stressful as [ __ ] to have I'm sure
people come up and you've inspired them
of course and that's wonderful but now
that I have to like maintain and
obviously like make that part of your
content is that stressful or is it like
I love doing this this is great honestly
I am glad we're talking about this
because up until like two weeks ago
if a guy was good and now actually maybe
like a month ago that's when I for the
first time I think I kind of hit a wall
really and for the first time ever it's
been kind of hard for me to get back on
it yeah I feel like I've I'm doing it
still and I'm going through the motions
just because I conditioned myself to do
it it's a routine yeah but mentally I'm
in a different place now and it didn't
hit me until I just went on like a
little live show thing for my podcast
with Alicia and in the meet and greets B
I had never talked about it before and I
was kind of like after doing like
Coachella
I like weekend one because I'm like
doing all that stuff and just like
having fun and then trying to force
myself to get back into it I was like oh
like this I don't want to I don't want
to do this anymore like yeah and I'm for
the first time in a year and a half I'm
having those thoughts and then going
straight to a live show and a meet and
greet people being like you changed my
life like because of you I've done this
because of this like because of you I'm
getting myself up every day to go to the
gym like [ __ ] like yeah then the
pressure really did hit me in those
meeting gree yeah so for the first time
ever I'm feeling that now that's yeah I
mean it must be nuts
I mean I've we've had young girls come
up to us but we're like comedy girls and
so it's all very casual and you guys you
lead with such sincerity about the stuff
that you do that it must be really
stressful to have people like really
young girls come up to you and be like
you change like you influence for lack
of a better how I lived my life every
day
that's kind of nuts I mean what
everything yeah what's like so you guys
just did a bunch of live shows what's
like the average age of the person that
comes to live show to the live shows it
was there were a good amount of younger
girls but I feel like also with the
podcast we've aged up so yeah a lot of
our age but meet-and-greets i would say
are younger because my parents bring
them and then the actual attendees other
than the meet and greet people work
around my gotcha gotcha
yeah what's it like doing the podcast
live terrifying yeah I just talk and I
talk and I talk I'm like oh okay we're
gonna edit that one out later maybe but
a lot of people just heard that it
doesn't completely go into the void
actually listen to this out of my mouth
400 people every night um what okay I
also want to talk about honey pop beauty
is this a thing that's still happening
yeah well I think it was I'm trying to
figure out what I want to do with it it
started out it's such a before I even
started my whole health journey is when
I started or came up with the idea so
that has grown so much as I've grown
mm-hm and so now I'm at this point where
I'm like okay I'm not really sure what I
want to do I would love to expand more
with it but also like I've changed
completely as a person
mm-hmm my interests have changed
everything about my lifestyle has
changed like when I started out doing
that my lifestyle was so sedentary yeah
and I was just like hanging out at home
all the time and I was like hanging out
with my friends and dogs doing girls
nights all the time so I was like I'll
do a face mask that was fun at the time
now I'm like never home so I never
really have time to do that yeah yeah
that's kind of like seeing where I want
to go with the brand and kind of
changing and evolving with my new
lifestyle mmm I really no idea what I'm
gonna do
welcome to the club we're all kind of
floundering right now it's real I love
it I want to go back to you punching
your brother in the face I get to hear
this story
okay can I hear this story you know I
don't even know where this Galvis yeah I
didn't know I ever talked about it my
brother wasn't sure I'd love to go off I
just remember I remember I just wanted
to use the washer but he was using it he
wouldn't let me use it so I just punched
him in the face oh my god I don't like
break us apart I don't remember ever
telling anyone about this
I don't think it was that dramatic and I
see him I just remember being like
physically held back by my dad that mean
try to throw punches drones got a
cleaner clothes you also going back now
to fitness journey love a soul cycle yes
have you seen I mean in LA tons of
celebrities frequent soul cycle have you
seen many there never have I seen any
well I think I kind of got into it I
feel like it's not that trendy anymore
oh I in the beginning 90 minutes a whole
goddamn way yeah exactly I wish I had
been in in the beginning because I would
have loved like sweat next to Justin
Bieber's I think actually find a fact
I've become best I do this weird thing
where I like target and instructor and
I'm like I want to be your friend yeah
at one point I actually dated one no I
got was dating like I fully I like met
the parents I did all this stuff like I
was in a white dress was very confused
how that one happened but we don't talk
to him I've become best friends
I found a gay one best friend there you
go say fully crisis to her do it that
one and so I became best friends them
and he told me that Justin Bieber would
it like a ride with him occasion in the
beginning but he would like book out
like a whole like square of bikes around
him so no one could like be next thing I
know interesting he also told me it's
not that big of a room it's not both so
that's like five hundred dollars every
cut us right something like that yeah I
mean he's got the money but he would say
how the classes are only 45 minutes but
he would come in 10 minutes late I also
don't know if I'm allowed to tell this
story I mean Justin is a huge fan of the
podcast he will hear he said that he
would come in like 10 to 15 minutes late
in the middle of like a square of bikes
and then leave like five minutes early
so it's only 43 songs and then leave and
he's also making so much more of a scene
by coming in late to this like empty
area of bikes and then leaving while
everyone's still like doing their cool
down I don't understand what he got out
of that but
I mean he's a he's an enigma to us all
he really is apparently then he would
like strip down his Calvin's just like
in the like areas like the open area
which is also a site like TMZ would pay
good money for that yeah I would get a
good picture and then pay for my selves
I go for the oh my god yeah have you
ever seen any like well obviously you've
probably seen photos of fans taking
inappropriate pictures of you have you
ever had like the weirdest fan
experience we just um we're just like
not even weird in a negative sense
necessarily just like strange yeah one
time I feel like I have to ish stories
and nothing really that crazy happens to
me I feel like everyone's always pretty
respectful I'm not like a david dobrik
or like a Jake Potter like I wish no I
don't know you know I was I don't know
baby girl you don't wish that you would
no I don't wish I was trying to wait for
my car at the valet at the Grove okay
and then like about 10 girls got out of
like a car and just like formed a circle
and just started screaming and then they
huddled around me start just like just
like ice form a seer I mean just start
screaming and I my like immediate
response is like it's a fighter flight I
like was like I need water and I just
like ran to like grab a lot of all my
friends just stuck there he's just like
what's going on and I just like ran away
and then they all just like take their
cameras out sorta like filming our
screaming oh no and I like didn't know
what to do sighs I don't think I'd be
good in those situations and I think
that was just like I got in the car
after is terrifying it was ten little
girls forming a like a formation like
Mighty Ducks formation around just like
I just yeah just let her like just run
like just I don't even know what to do I
got in the car and the FIR I always ask
my friends as I like leave these
situations like was I nice because I
truly black out yeah you I don't even
know how to there's no cracks or a
situation like that when like people
other people who are waiting for their
cars were also looking like who the [ __ ]
is this girl I'm just like don't even
know and then another time I went to
Hawaii was like years ago this is very
early on in my youtube career so I'd
never really still don't really
experience much like this but I remember
I tweeted out that I was like in Hawaii
or whatever and then some
girls like messaged me that they wanted
to come meet me but I didn't really know
what to do and I was kind of confused so
she's like I'm going in the mall like if
you want to meet up there like with sure
I'll meet up and then they like
something happen where they like
couldn't meet me and they're like we're
just yelling me all these things and I
was like okay whatever got back to my
hotel room and there's two presents
sitting on my bed like in my room and I
was just so confused and I still don't
really understand what I think they went
to the hotel told them they were like
looking for me I think I got you to
leave the room wait did this moment
friends now very nice baby she seems
very sweet I never fully asked I think
either like they asked the hotel to let
them up and in other rooms or they like
gave it to the hotel talk for like
please put them in the room okay
this was also like 2013 so like it
wasn't I mean still should have been a
big deal but I feel like now like his
hotel is know also like yeah we
shouldn't like do that or they say no or
like I get calls to the hotels now like
how you've a package yeah please sorry
no thank you it's interesting sometimes
nothing like crazy crazy but like those
little things yeah yeah yeah we were
like you know that it's all like coming
from a good place but there's a little
bit like if this was a middle-aged man
doing this it would be a different
scenario sort of think oh yes okay who
texts and calls each other more about
their everyday struggles you were Alicia
oh definitely I definitely call her a
lot more really I text her a lot more
and I'm also like the type of like
incessant text or it's like line line
like sentences were out in like
paragraphs so you send multiple texts oh
yeah yeah I would say if I'm trying to
tell her one story
there's about 25 texts and she doesn't
reply within an hour and I was something
else they I just continue talking and
I'm like she'll see it eventually
well she's free she's obviously very
busy she's very busy
that's very funny do you guys have like
a safe word when you guys like get out
of social situations together oh there's
a thing we say I don't know if I'm
allowed to say it but I'm the favorite
way for a story to start - can I say it
he's also her publisher yeah
but we also can edit out anything after
the fact if you go back and you're like
not so safe stop me it's not bad it's
just like if we're in public
and then one of us the thing is I think
sometimes subscribers don't realize how
apparent they're being they're like yeah
you're like two feet away and so we just
like whisper to each other we say you've
got mail and that's when you know
there's someone else you gotta say I
mean cuz you you had developed like a
this very keen perception when you know
that someone's like notice you earlier
there's a camera yeah oh that's so nuts
but also that's great that's a great
catchphrase
he started it I can't take any credit
she taught it to me at the Grove and
we're just like doing something stupid
so you got mail
okay ex neighbor Melissa oh my god
what's this story I named her Melissa
quote Melissa I gotta set the name I
gave her okay so basically I had fresh
out of dropping out of one year in three
weeks of college I moved to LA and I had
just moved am on my own for the first
time ever right I think it was like
maybe a couple weeks in to living alone
I get this maybe even like the first
week it was very new okay I get a knock
on my door I open it up and luckily it
was always when a friend was there so I
was never like alone but they were just
weren't staying the night and so um I
got a done knock on my door and this
woman my her name I guess I named her
mullet I totally forgot Melissa she was
she lived right directly underneath me
okay and the first time she came over
and was like hi I just want to like
she's wearing I vividly remember Air
Jordans she was about five eight a very
short buzzcut Air Jordans it like
whatever Michael Jordan like basketball
shorts light blue those shimmery ones
yeah white Hanes tank top she's like hey
just what I'm like introduce myself I
was like hi nice to meet you
she's like I brought you over a gift I
was also underage but she gave me
champagne so I was like thank you
and then she's like I didn't like
introduce myself like can I come in I
was like okay so she like walks into my
place and then her little like half
balding dog named shadow also runs and I
have a dog and my dogs like what the
[ __ ] get this thing and I guess they got
this thing out of my house
I like pick up my dog shadows like
running around I have a friend is just
stay on the couch chilling essentially
long story short she like it was very
nice the first time yeah after that over
the next like couple months or so she
would like come over but she'd be
belligerently drunk and like banging on
my door and like screaming at me and
like they were like trying to come over
trying to hang out all the time and it
just got to this point where like it was
so no it was just and you know it's
invasive it was completely invasive I
felt violated and then I would like tell
the apartment complex but you know how
none of them care oh yeah yeah they're
like huh sorry yeah
and then you just feel unsafe exactly
and she was just like I felt like she
was gonna like hurt me sometimes yeah so
eventually I moved out my only my dumb
ass moved down just two doors down I
[Laughter]
have to save myself to the next unit
over essentially and I but I fully was
like I my fear II was she would just get
so drunk and she would get mad that I
was like stomping my feet when I was and
I was sitting but it was just she would
come up with complaint exactly so she
just got so drunk in her head and I
think she was also very lonely all these
things so she would just like try to
hang out and then when I went wanna hang
out she would just get mad and she's
like you're stomping and so mmm I fully
convinced myself that if I'd moved just
even one door over she'll never find she
would never she wouldn't care anymore
I remember one time she even went when I
did love live directly above her she I
got a new car and that day she came over
to my apartment was like hey I was like
I she's like you got a new car like the
day oh and it was just like a lot of
weird stuff so I moved over and I was
like if I move over she can't get mad at
me because I'm not stomping on her
ceiling anymore so I remember a new girl
moved in I was like baby
so sorry she was around my age kidding
she's like 20 21 and I was about to
leave for like playlist live or
something back when I used to go to
those and I remember it was like 2:00
a.m. I was like packing my suitcase and
I just hear like the loudest banging and
screaming of my life and I like there's
like two doors down like poke my head
out and she's just bang on this poor
girl's door and I was like trying I
think I've logged it I think I got like
audio of it actually before this let me
rewind my aunt who lived a couple miles
away from me at the time was I didn't
want to tell my mom because I knew my
mom would make me move home I told my
aunt it was like really cool and I
always kept your updated with things and
then after like the fourth or fifth
incident she was like [ __ ] this like you
know I'm coming over
yeah she drove over I still have the
bottle of champagne I was using it as
evidence now like leverage on my stories
so she came over and took the champagne
and went down and I remember I recorded
audio because I lived at like an outdoor
complex out here and my aunt was just
like you need to leave my niece alone
like this is absolutely like
unacceptable and over lunch she is
underage like you're bothering her like
this is not okay and then I just hear
this like top of her lungs you're like
[ __ ] you get off my poverty you don't
know my god just Chuck's the champagne
and then I move then I hear this banging
on this girl's poor girl's door her name
was Justine sweet Justine we become
snapchat friends and I had like I think
I had warned her of just like just so
you know like ice live here in just in
case yeah this was the first incident
was like the worst I've ever seen and so
she's like banging banging banging like
screaming and the poor girl is like
inside terrified yeah and I like
recorded some of it and then suddenly
like maybe an hour passes by and I hear
like a lot of voices outside look
outside there's like sixteen policemen
out oh my god and like all this stuff
happened and then her dad ended up being
a lawyer the girl's debt yeah of course
Wow lucky Melissa yeah so she's there
like a whole loss who got involved they
like interrogated me asked me also
almost ended up being an uber driver so
imagine like shoes or uber driver
I can't wait the white Mercedes one got
everything
and so she got kicked out and then she
moved the other girl moved out and then
I also moved out I hope that your paths
don't cross again sounds insane I kind
of do a new story time Oh also thank you
for being here I know you went to see
ariana grande last night I have to tell
you I did not drink any alcohol because
I was trying to save my voice for the
pot oh you run for the team you're a
real sweet kind wonderful meanwhile I'm
drinking a Bloody Mary while we're
recording how was the concert incredible
you're also you're very much like a big
music person you go to Coachella a lot
we have a ton of questions about chance
the rapper for you eventually he's not
here what's been your favorite concert
that you've ever gone to oh good
question I think hmm I can tell you my
least favorite yeah I would love to hear
the ABC oh really yeah electric dance
electric daisy carnival the very true
raise that's in Vegas right yes I went
to Vegas I went to New York I was I went
to both and but they were both for brand
deals and so God being there like
working yeah very interesting
and those are intense if you're not
going for the pure joy of rave exactly
yeah what's interesting is that they
start at about midnight and you know
till like 8:00 a.m. mm-hmm
so I would arrive at like 11:00 p.m. to
work and I would just be it was it was
an interesting experience
yeah that's intense hmm I do love
Coachella though yeah how many times
have you gone mmm
I think this is my third year go yeah
third you're going and then I win
weekend one and two last year and this
year sweet okay what's your biggest
piece of advice for anyone that's never
been Oh mmm I would just say prepare
yourself yeah I feel like you just gotta
like mentally prepare yourself mm-hmm I
think I saw I saw a meme saying that
Coachella is like the Olympics for
influencers yeah I saw that I think it's
very true
get them picks exactly I'd say I'm like
I saw like bronze medalist four oh she's
so humble okay we're taking one last
break and then when we get back we have
a billion Twitter questions for you so
we'll be right back with more nacho deep
yeah yeah when it comes to shopping for
clothes most of us are amateurs I don't
mean to drag you but you know it's true
so why not let a professional handle it
with stitch fix a stylist will do all
the work for you stitch fix is an online
personal styling service that delivers
your favorite clothing shoes and
accessories directly to you you just
complete a style profile and your expert
personal stylist will send you a box of
hand-picked items from brands you know
and love with exclusive styles you won't
find elsewhere they even have men's and
kids boxes I know if all you kids that
love listen to this podcast you got a
box with stitch fix with no subscription
required pick between automatic
shipments or getting new pieces on
demand shipping exchanges and returns
are always free plus the $20 styling fee
is automatically applied towards
anything you keep from your box get
started today with stitch fix calm slash
grace and get an extra 25% off when you
keep everything in your box but stitch
fix calm slash grace stitch fix calm
slash grace if there is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help online counseling can
actually help they offer licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBT matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment get help at
your own time at your own pace anything
you share is confidential and it's
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist what a
millennial way to get help if for some
reason you're not happy with your
counselor you can always request a new
one at any time for no additional charge
and best of all it's affordable and not
too deep with grace helbig listeners get
10% off your first month with the
discount code grace so get started today
by going to better help calm slash grace
fill out a questionnaire that will help
assess your needs and match you with a
counselor that you'll love that's better
help calm slash grace we're back before
we get into these Twitter questions real
quick I'm gonna ask you the two
questions I ask every single guest
that's on the podcast oh my gosh okay
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
I don't know why my brain went to Zac
Efron but I he seems nice yeah and it
doesn't have to be a malicious thing oh
yeah it can be an enjoyable experience
Emmy
he might be soup that might be his kink
you don't know huh okay I love that sir
the other question I ask every single
guests to do this to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or like a close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so for example mine
is a college jogging front lawn yeah I
can be a pissing your pants story it can
be just a bathroom emergency story I'm
trying to imagine where you are at right
now oh I was on that I was on the front
lawn like five miles from my parents I
had a recent experience yes Coachella
Billy Eilish
just made it okay I mean if you want to
tag that on to the advice for anyone at
Coachella I'll be know your surroundings
be aware sir yes you've got mail with
the bathroom exactly okay let's get into
these Twitter questions someone to know
which alcohol would you never drink
again
and why oh my god oh I've got two really
good stories okay I also love that this
is very own brand for me now I've really
my meet and greets for the shows on the
hakka shows changed from receiving
stuffed animals to handles of Tito's
which I think
that's too much perfect glow up that's
my eye I did my boxing I'm at Tito's
soda girl all damn day me too I'm a
cutie toes water crystal light what the
[ __ ] you name that drink oh my god no
you guys should name that drink if it is
it just a you drink or is it like a you
and Alicia like a skinny [ __ ] drink
like it's a well known thing is that in
that realm but things I you wouldn't
ever drink again
I mean I would do it yeah again I don't
have anything I wouldn't do again okay
but just a bad experience was I went to
a bar in New York recently and some
subscriber came up and was like I'm
gonna buy you shoes I was like yeah
let's go yeah and she bought me
something called a pickle back oh you
try yeah girl I got I was big into
pickle backs is it a thing I lived in
Brooklyn for like five or six years
before I moved out here to Los Angeles
and right when like the year before I
was leaving pickle backs became this
like trendy Williamsburg started thing
that everyone was doing whiskey and
pickle and I never it's whiskey pickle
juice in a the pickle juice cancels out
the whiskey it's like a magic bullet the
magic trick in your mouth and I never
drink whiskey but I was like I'll drink
this cuz I like pickle juice yeah and
this cancels it out but they're
dangerous it was well I enjoyed the
experience they did work very well and
so and I had never had whiskey up until
that oh yeah yeah and then I also forgot
the whole like clear verses non clear
liquor store so went hard with the vodka
water crystal it so that's mics that you
can imagine how my night went yeah your
your body's not gonna love that petri
dishes but now I know for next time so I
will be doing them again yes need to
I've conditioned that day the course
exactly someone to know was YouTube your
original plan or were you originally
going to pursue a different career what
you kind of talked about yeah that you
went to school and then YouTube kind of
became this exactly was gonna try and be
a physician's assistant
and really yeah that was the full plan
but it's like because I was gonna do
that I meet all the prereqs go to PA
school there you go then well that
always be there if the Internet's down
tomorrow that is true but also recently
someone got a cut on their knee and I
almost passed out so like that is all
sort of advice if you want to go into
the medical field practice that
beforehand I don't know that's something
you can like get used to yeah I don't
think you I mean you don't want to be
operating or helping someone in like I'm
Samedi someone's no youtube celebrity
crush oh my gosh okay there's this guy
that I have a crush on but I don't know
his name but I've also met him multiple
times okay his channel is the odd ones
out you know familiar nose like an
animated channel cool I have a weird
thing for like animation channels shows
in general I really love them I think
he's so cool and I don't know his name
but I feel like it's okay because he has
an animated channels like yeah you know
I also feel like that's like a Google
search away yeah make some mysterious
eyes like his name is Ryan
oh it's James uh his name is James
his name is quote Melissa um someone to
know what's the worst job you've ever
had I've actually never had a job before
really it was my first job was your
first ever job Wow I try to do a pet
service when I was younger one
door-to-door actually no no I made
flyers and put them in people's
mailboxes saying that I would watch
their pets and then someone came out
that it's illegal to put things in their
mailbox my work I think I have today you
got a gardener and get it until someone
cause you this is illegal
someone to know what's your favorite
cheat meal uh I love I do this thing
where I leave the bar I owe my cheat
meals rewards when I'm drunk
oh yeah you know obviously yes I just
call that meals like planet where I'm
leaving the bar start the post mates so
that by the time I get home my food
arrives oh I love that even in your
drunk state you're so efficient like
I've got it down to a science
and like kind of like I decide my cheat
meal before I go out to so it's like I
know like the wait time for it too it's
like either thirty forty-five really the
5560 like you and me are the same person
we were flying back from New York and
she was buying herself kedo groceries on
the plane landed exactly when she landed
it was like otherwise it's like it just
doesn't work out I've learned the hard
way it doesn't tonight time it and it's
usually there's this place at downtown
called um I like cafe okay and they're
open 24/7 and they have like I usually
get about like five things and I just
pick it all of it it's like a burger and
fries there are these really good tacos
they have this like cereal milk shake
and then that's dangerous they're potato
chips are really good too so it's just
all that and just me at my table just
like oh she's back and I'm like send him
up and he comes someone to know who was
your childhood crush Jesse McCartney oh
[Music]
yeah I would buy them what my dad would
buy me the magazines at like Borders
bookstore uh-huh and then I would rip
out all his posters and I had a full
collage like about five feet by about
ten feet just plastered of his face
which I really wish I had pictures of I
just don't have you ever met him no I
don't think so I mean there's still time
I feel like you're in a position where
that can happen
I think he got married so I don't think
I want to meet him yeah yeah I mean I
mean not on there just they said all 60%
end in divorce
you guys have guests on
someone to know what ways do you find 2d
stress on your own besides working out I
honestly just hold my dog and just like
cuddling with my dog yeah tears yeah
just like I think it's just like let it
out you can't suppress it I feel like
for a long time I suppress and then
after the podcast I realized like wow
you got some issues man and now I just
like let it out it's a it's a healthy
thing Oh a hundred percent rather out
than in
speaking of dogs someone said if you
could be a specific breed of puppy what
would it be oh that's a good question
not a goldendoodle Goldendoodles freaked
me out
have you seen one they're so big and
like the word doodle
to me insinuates little even but like
it's a what is that it's a it's a Golden
Retriever with a poodle but like a
standard poodle oh there are many that
live in my building and I think about
that I think I would just love to
specifically be my dog because she's got
it made Daisy Daisy yeah three sir how
long did you have days or how long have
you had my daughter I write about my
after the three weeks of dropping out so
I got her in college she lived in that
house with me should not have had a dog
in college let me tell you that but
she's been through it with me wow she
just like lives her life she's right now
at the groomers got a healthy spot
getting her nails trim like she lives
the life she's a full LA dog she is yeah
she went from the Inland Empire to LA
she really made it someone was being
ordering takeout after a night of
drinking pretty or basic I think it's
both oh yeah
I'm smiling someone said I wants to know
what's your favorite and least favorite
youtube trend Oh favorite trend
man I really liked the let's go at least
favorite what's your least favorite I
think the 20-foot granite I think I've
done a couple the 24-hour challenges
were really dumb what is I don't even
know what these are you locked herself
in a room for 24 hours but you choose
what rooms like Alicia did her back
through my closet granted I'm planning
on doing one very soon I think that
they're very strange yeah um yeah that
was a weird trend I know that someone
summit recently said they went to prison
for 24 hours just like 24 hour
challenges okay are interesting but they
are very entertaining yeah the one now
of the person in front of me through
yeah how does I don't even know how that
works how do you get them to order a
pictorial dad until I yeah I have a
leash explain it to me she you go to the
drive-thru and then you when you go to
order you're like I'll have whatever the
person in front of me just ordered oh
nice yeah I don't know I'm not gonna I
never suck bones never do that stuff so
it doesn't really appeal to me yeah I
was gonna say do you try to keep up with
like how do you get your ideas for your
content just your own brain I wanted to
throw a birthday party so I contacted
him he threw a full birthday party and I
was like well this gives me content for
a month so let's just ride this that
gave me a theory that's a big serialize
everything exactly uh um someone wants
to know if you had a warning label what
would it say beware there you go that's
a good one yeah that's pretty that
covers all the bases
yeah um what's your one regret in life
I'm very wait as I'm sitting here okay
I'm gonna use this as my segue okay I
pulled up some pictures that I wanted I
think I know I've been watching YouTube
for a long time as we've been talking
about on this process Remmy came in and
was like I have a surprise I'm gonna do
something at some point during your
podcast
it was the most [ __ ] ominous thing
like what 40 minutes it's happening to
me now a pear
this I would date back to I think
2012-2013 I was just starting my channel
yes I was about to drive myself to
Walmart to buy myself some ASP camp Oh
what I'm gonna need you to close your
eyes uh-huh and then just looking look
at those you could scroll five times
what what what oh I bet I did in 2012 oh
my god also and then there's no speaking
my you don't know it's just me yesterday
oh my god no I don't even remember the
question but I just wanted to share that
with you I've wanted to for my whole
life love it a friend in the pictures
that contact her yesterday and said I
want you know I'm gonna be on her
podcast and she lost her [ __ ]
that's incredible oh this is so much
like sweeter and nicer than what I
thought I was gonna be like me
shit-faced with you at like VidCon oh
that's so awesome yeah it was really fun
that grace face long live god bless I
mean also I never came up with it it's
an actual pose that existed before wait
really well I mean like people called it
grace face but they're doing it but I
don't even remember what the question
was but I figured that was my that
answered it whatever the question was
the day that your video came out where
you hazed me hi screams bloody murder in
my dance it's like literally like
running laughs and then like ended up in
the spinning around
that's incredible thanks for watching
for so long today so I mean I like trust
me I've been watching all of you guys
like a full time creep for years because
I love like genuinely it's so soothing
to me to watch like beauty guru guru
videos because I'm like this is not the
life I can never leave I love how it's
calming in some way to watch vicariously
these other girls like actually thrive
with their hygiene
their interior designs and all of it
thank you so much of course okay couple
more questions yeah we're almost through
the end someone's no what are you
binging right now
planet Earth oh yeah I love planet Earth
oh it's really if you ever smoke weed
and watch planet Earth it's a real good
time just oh it's great everything looks
like a cartoon it looks like a Pixar
movie and you'll scream at the your TV
actually yeah yeah okay yeah I'm
interesting just but I mean I'm giving
life hacks to I'm also a lifestyle
someone was no issue single if not hey
there what's your YouTube guilty
pleasure or is there like a
is there someone you follow on Instagram
or something you follow on Instagram or
Twitter that's like a full guilty
pleasure I don't know if it's a guilt I
feel like this is just a weird thing I
do but while I'm doing my eating after a
night out that's gonna mean it's not me
now but that'll be me tomorrow that's
how I think about it okay last question
someone's know what's your favorite
question to be asked Wow
yeah um maybe it hasn't happened yet you
know what I like I like when people I
like when I do a Q&A or I'm like I'm
doing this to ask me questions and
people are just like how are you doing
and something kind of like invasive or
like kind of mean it's always just like
you genuinely want to know yeah yeah I
think that's always like a nice thing
and it's always a nice prompt for you to
check in with yourself to to be like how
am i doing exactly that just like
standard response of like I'm fine wait
a minute mhm and then I can hold my dog
in crummy this was so fun thank you so
much for being here
we completely finish every guest on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie from us I am so you can open it
and read whatever fortune is inside it
might have something to do with you I
don't know oh my god wait there's no oh
it's a weird prank that we
okay this is a really fun idea to start
doing okay
your brother lied he totally does watch
your videos I guess no Jani nothing I
think he does listen to everything I do
oh he's grown to be a fan as I give him
money when he asks he's grown to be a
freak that's amazing okay I mean where
can people find you the podcast
everything you're up to if they don't
know my channels are mr. Ashton or M
life and then podcast is pretty basic
sweetie I want you guys doing more live
shows um maybe maybe a little it was
emotionally draining so I need a little
break for a minute yeah and then like
that maybe okay look follow her on all
social media platforms because you'll
get all the up-to-date information there
yeah thank you again for being here
we'll see you guys next time I'm not too
deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
whatever struggles you're facing whether
depression or anxiety or trauma or grief
better help can connect you with a
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment it's so
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions or chat and text with
your therapist and anything you share is
completely confidential best of all it
is affordable and not too deep with
grace Helbig listeners even get 10% off
your first month with the discount code
grace so get started by going to better
help calm slash grace filling out a
questionnaire and get matched with the
council counselor you'll love today
you
[Music]